good news for Star Wars fans as ahsoka
tano will appear in the second season of
the Disney plus series the Mandalorian
according to Deadline actress rosario
Dawson has been signed for this role
the fans are of course excited even if
currently only a guest role as planned
actress rosario Dawson is known from the
Sin City movies and Marvel's daredevil
among others
her character ahsoka tano is known from
the animation series Star Wars the Clone
Wars a member of the intelligent people
of the Toccata and born on the planet
Chile
she began her training as a Jedi at the
age of three and after the outbreak of
the Clone Wars she was assigned to the
Jedi Knight Anakin Skywalker as a
Padawan the relationship between the two
is very difficult in the beginning but
develops over time into a close bond the
fact that rosario Dawson takes over the
role of ahsoka tano has met with
positive approval from fans so far the
second season of the Mandalorian is
scheduled to start this autumn but the
worldwide pandemic could put a damper on
the whole thing shortly after 2018
DC's Aquaman was released and a huge
success at the box office
it was obvious that there would be a
second part now the first details of the
plot are revealed as screenwriter David
Leslie Johnson mccottry answered some
fan questions on Twitter when asked if
there is a specific comic template for
the new movie the author answered that
Aquaman 2 is not based on a specific
story but has many elements of the
so-called Silver Age storyline with
Black Manta more precisely this means
that we can probably count on an intense
battle between Aquaman and Black Manta
apart from Jason Momoa the cast will
also include jaya abdullah teen as his
opponent Black Manta whether willem
dafoe
and Nicole Kidman will also play a role
in the second part is not yet clear this
cinema release of Aquaman 2 is scheduled
for December 16th in 2022 most people
know Angry Birds as a mobile game
classic or more recently as a movie the
only thing that's really missing is a
serious isn't it that's probably what
Rovio entertainment and cake thought
because together with Netflix they want
to produce their
own serious about the colorful pigs and
birds the serious is supposed to have
over 40 episodes each of them will be
about 11 minutes long the story revolves
around teenage versions of red bump and
Chuck who spent the summer together in a
camp the rival camp consists who would
have thought it of pigs therefore there
should be a fair amount of conflict
potential it is currently not known when
Netflix plans to release the series
after we already announced some
postponement of upcoming movies and
ongoing serious productions last week
there are more top-class movies and
serious since then that will do the same
and stop their production first of all
there is the Walking Dead series its
final episode where the title a certain
doom won't be broadcasted on US
television on April 12th as planned
therefore the release of the episode in
other countries will also be canceled a
new date for the release of episode 16
is not yet known but AMC announced that
the season finale will be released later
this year as a kind of special episode
this is more than understandable as The
Walking Dead team is currently already
having difficulties completing the
post-production of season 10
successfully on AMC's Twitter channel
the first photo from the final episode
was posted showing Norman Reedus
character Daryl Dixon standing among a
bunch of fighters for non-english
speaking countries the impact will also
be significant as the current situation
means that in most countries the latest
episodes cannot be synchronized at the
moment Warner Brothers and ICI have a
similar situation as their movie Wonder
Woman 1984 will not be able to keep its
actual release date either the parties
involved have decided to postpone the
film until August 14th for the time
being
previous on-demand release is probably
not relevant at the moment
director patty Jenkins explained the
reason for this on Twitter where she
said that Wonder Woman 1984 was made for
the big screen and that local cinema
owners would benefit from seeing the
blockbuster exclusively in the cinema
however many people think that the new
date for August is hard to maintain as
most people expect that the world
cinemas who won't open their doors again
by mid-august however there are good
news from China where things are slow
but surely returning to normal in many
parts of the country and while the last
cinemas around the world are closing
China is in the process of opening them
since the worldwide film industry is at
a standstill at the moment and no new
movies are being produced they decided
to simply show some classics on screen
among them are some Avengers movies and
James Cameron's Avatar bizarrely enough
avatar could now regain the first place
of the most successful movies of all
times because the difference in the
income of the two movies is only a
ridiculous 9 million u.s. dollars this
amount could be brought into the cinemas
by the huge Chinese film industry in a
few days assuming that of course more
people want to see Avatar than the
parallel running Avengers endgame which
most journalists assume regarding the
more than 10 years ago release date of
course we will keep you up to date on
all the consequences of the virus on the
movie industry in the coming weeks
[Music]